let's continue learning
excel and how excel can be used
for data analysis now we have seen
sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression
now what is regression so when you talk
about statistical modeling regression
analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between two or more variables and
basically we would want to look at
two or more variables and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response
or the target right so for example if we
look at our data here we have
temperature
we have price of ice cream and then we
have units sold
and we can go ahead and make predictions
so for example when you look at
regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics
you have anova you have
different plots which we have here which
is x variable
x variable 2 and then you have normal
probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your
add-in that is data analysis which helps
you in doing different kind of data
analysis here
right now how do we do this so we have
our variables here which is temperature
price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression
we need to understand which one of these
are independent variables which one of
these are
dependent variables right so when you
talk about your
x that's your independent variable or we
can say predictor
or explanatory so when you talk about
your independent variables
or as we say predictors or
explanatory variables these are the
factors
that might influence the dependent
variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or target
that's the main factor you're trying to
understand or predict
so we can plot a scatter plot to see
relationship between variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively
related negatively related and so on
we can also get values
such as r square which is coefficient of
determination
regression line and then analyze
the relationship between variables so
here is one of the links of
one of my edits other videos where we
are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression
but that's programmatically and using a
processing framework such as spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel
so basically we would want to use our
variables which is temperature
price of ice cream units sold and then
get these plots so what we can do is for
example
i can get rid of this and might be i can
just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said
when we talk about your regression
analysis
we need to understand whether we have
one variable
or we have multiple variables right
so you might have heard of univariate
analysis bivariate analysis and so on
well here we are focusing more on
using excel to do our regression
analysis
so i will not go deeper into regression
topics
but certain things as basics should be
known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do
it helps you understand how the
dependent variable
changes when one
or more independent variables vary
and it basically allows us to
mathematically determine
which of those variables really has an
impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model
that is based on the sum of squares
which is basically a mathematical way to
find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal of the model is to get
the smallest possible sum of squares
and draw a line that comes closest to
the data
so that's what we mean by our regression
line
or basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line
if there are residuals that is points
which do not fall
on the regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about statistics
we differentiate between a simple and
multiple linear regression
so you have something called a simple
linear regression
models which basically gives you the
relationship between dependent variable
and one independent variable using a
linear function
and if you use two or more variables
that is explanatory
variables to predict the dependent
variable we are actually dealing with
multiple linear regression so if the
dependent variable
is modeled as a non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we will see how
we can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream
we would want to find out how many units
were sold
now what we can do is we can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot
which is quite easy in excel so if you
have been given variables what you can
do is you can click on
insert you can then choose the kind of
plots which you want and here you have
insert scatter plot
so we can choose this and you can choose
the first option so that gives you a
blank
layout and what you can do is now you
need to select data
so for example let's click on select
data and then
you can say add so what we would want
is we can give a name so we want x
values
and we want our y values right
so when you talk about y that's your
dependent variable
or your response or target so that is in
our case units sold
and x values are one set
of features or variables or multiple
variables so here
i can click on this series x values and
then i can
select this now in y values what i can
do
is i can select these and then
i can just say okay so that shows me
that it would be giving me a regression
scatter plot now let's say okay
and we have some points plotted here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable
such as temperature or price of ice
cream
you could as well do that now what you
can also do is you can add more meaning
to this
by giving in a title or you can also go
into quick layout
and you have various options here so you
see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series
and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line
that also gives you your r square and
that gives you your y
and x that is your coefficients so
let's select this one and then we have
some values which we can use to compare
this also shows me the regression line
and you can keep this for reference if
you would want you can change
the chart title to something else a
scatter plot
of dependent
was independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and we can get rid of this one so we
have series and we can say
what are these points if you would want
to add in legend
if you would want to do that or i can
just get rid of this
and i will keep these values here
which we will see when we do a data
analysis we can
always compare these values so
here i have created a simple scatter
plot
and then i can look at dependent wise
independent variables
or i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my
x-axis what is my y-axis
so basically you can here
say for example just say y and might be
here i will say x and we can
rename that later now how do we perform
data analysis
or get into regression right now what we
would want to do
is we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation
you might have known about it so it is
basically
why when you say y
equals you can say
bx plus a plus
c and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression
when x is your independent variable
y is your dependent variable
your a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to zero
so basically on a regression graph
that's the point where line crosses the
y axis
and that's your intercept when you talk
about b
that's basically your slope of
regression line
which is the rate of change for y
as x changes and then you also
have your constant right so that's your
uh sorry that's basically your random
error term
right which is basically the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value
so your linear equation always
has an error term because in real life
predictors are
obviously never perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to y is b x
plus a and that's the equation of a line
we can look into this and the linear
equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in
excel so what we can simply do is
[Music]
here let me yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression
so that's what we would want to do now
we'll say okay
now here you need to give your input y
range so as i said
you will have to select the dependent
and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here
and here we have your x and y
so y being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable
or multiple variables so i will select
temperature
price of ice cream and then since we
have chosen the headings we will go for
labels
right now we can always look at the
confidence level we can change that so
you can say whether you want it in a new
worksheet or you can just say output
range
and i will probably just click here
and select one of the cell here now we
can
also choose the other options which we
would want to see
as a part of this regression analysis so
basically we
have selected input y range which is
your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable
and if we are building a multi
regression model
then we have chosen temperature and
price of ice cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range
which is basically on this sheet and
then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you your
residuals
now we can also get your line fit plots
which you were seeing earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots
and then basically just say okay
and let's say okay and that
basically gives you your regression
analysis output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have
anova we have our serial output that's
from the previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics
we also have our plots so we can
basically look into these so we have our
normal
let's get rid of these let's get rid of
this
let's get rid of this and then
what we can do is since we had some
existing data it has overwritten so let
me get rid of this and i'll repeat this
step again
and let's say water
yeah so now what we want to do is we
want to do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis
we choose regression we have already
chosen our
y range which is column c x range is
multiple variables we have gone for
labels output range which we would want
to select
a particular cell so let me select this
i'm going for residuals line fit plots
and normal probability plots
and say okay so now
we have our plots we can just separate
them
to have a better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables
so here it shows me units sold and then
what are the predicted units sold and
here the variable is temperature
here the variable is price of ice cream
right so that's your one variable and
second variable
and then you also have your normal
probability plot
now to interpret this or to understand
what we have here
where we look at your summary output
so it is good to understand what excel
is helping
us out so basically when we do a
regression in
excel it is performing all the
calculations
automatically the interpretation is
something which we need to understand so
basically we are looking at multiple
r value here and we can
let's also fine tune this one
here we have our values here and if you
see
we have our r square now
we can then basically look at our
multiple r so what is your multiple r
that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
[Music]
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between -1 and 1 and
its
absolute value indicates the
relationship
strength so the larger the absolute
value
the stronger the relationship so one
basically means a strong
positive relationship minus one means a
strong
negative relationship and zero means no
relationship at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient
of determination which is used as an
indicator
of the goodness of the fit so it
basically shows
how many points fall on the regression
line
so your r square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared
deviations of the original data from the
mean now when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square so
it is
basically we can be seeing
that this is 0.450788
that's the value which i'm talking about
so it basically means
45 of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words
45 of dependent variables that is your y
values are explained by
the independent variables that is your x
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted
r square it is the r square adjusted
for the number of independent variables
in the model
so you would want to use this value
instead of
r square for multiple regression
analysis
such as in our case now you also have
standard error
so that's basically goodness of fit
measure
that basically shows the precision of
your regression analysis
so the smaller the value the more
certain you can be about your regression
equation
when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage
of dependent variables variance that is
explained by the model
and standard error is basically an
absolute measure
that shows the average distance that the
data points fall from the
regression line so you will have to look
back into
regression statistics terminologies to
basically understand more of this
and if you're already from data science
background that then you already know
what i'm talking about
we are just seeing how excel easily
helps us
in doing these things now we can
also look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our
model which is 7. now when we talk about
regression analysis and if we look at
analysis of variance that is your anova
values here
so we basically see f you have
s s m s f and significance
f now to understand these
so basically what we are doing is or
what excel is doing is
it splits the sum of squares into
individual components
that give information about the levels
of variability
within your regression model so when you
talk about your df
that's basically the number of degrees
of freedom associated with the source of
variance
you have sum of squares that is your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the
total ss the better your model fits the
data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square
you have f is basically the f statistic
or you can say uh f test for the null
hypothesis basically it is used to
test the overall significance of the
model and then
you finally have your significance f
which is the p value of f so
uh when we when we usually talk about
seeing simple linear regression
the in anova part is
not really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance
f value that gives an idea of
how reliably or statistically
significant
our results are so if significance f
is less than 0.05
that's 5 percent our model is ok
if it is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent
variables right now we can also look at
the output of coefficients and that's
what
we would want to look at so you
basically have your
intercept here so when you talk about
your intercept
temperature price of ice cream so we
know we are looking at our variables
and then we are also look at looking at
our
intercept which basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically
enables you to build a linear regression
equation
in the form of y equals bx plus
a which i explained earlier and then
basically we can
understand our regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have
it shows what is the predicted units
sold
and then it also gives you your
residuals
so we can compare the estimated and
actual number of sold
umbrellas based on the observation so we
have 11.209
here and if you compare that's basically
12
the second one is 15 and here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of
actual units sold and what our
regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and we will see if there is any
difference or no
right so obviously there
will be or there would be some
difference because independent variables
are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals basically help us
in understanding how far the actual
values are
from the predicted values so
that's what we see here in the residual
section
so for example when we look at this one
which is 11.209
and the actual is 12 we see what is the
residual
and how far is the predicted value from
the
actual value so similarly we can also
look at the percentile values
so that gives you your probability
output and this is what we have in our
graphs so we have basically our
variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold
and the relationship between them we can
basically uh add in more details to this
particular plot
and you also have normal probability
plot
which is basically getting your values
from your
probability output here so this is how
you can perform a simple regression
analysis
and now what you can do is you can
as i said you can basically be looking
at your scatter plot
you can be looking at your y and x and
your r square values
right but remember what are the
variables which you are selecting
and then you can compare these
with basically the values what you see
here
so remember here i have chosen my
both set of variables and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact
on the response or on the target
so it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have created
or some people prefer to do it using
formulas
so basically we have some statistical
functions that it
can help you do linear regression
analysis such as
you have linus you have slope you have
intercept you have correlation and so on
so basically you can use these
particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to basically go in for
a function if that's what you would want
to do
and then you can search for functions
and say for example i'll just say
nest and say go and here i have my
function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that
what i will have to do is then select
the variable so if you just say okay
and that basically says your known y's
known x your constants your stats
and basically you can use the formula
also but we are not covering that here
might be in the later videos we can do
that so just try out
and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that
so that basically gives you an easier
way
of performing regression analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here